Wir haben quality options krasse scheiß twitch hat zugeschlagen quality options
poggers
habe ich den titel überhaupt richtig geschrieben weihnachtsgeschenke auf den letzten drücker ja
stimmt quality options sehr nice so jetzt mal die ganze scheiß aufmachen auf den
bildschirm oder warten bis twitch die notifications verschickt
so man kann das aller switch keine notifications verschickt gerade
doch lull nice
so ich kann aber nicht lange schon 21 11 also eine stunde oder so mal gucken oder eineinhalb
stunden schauen wir mal oh ich wusste mir fällt noch ein fällt noch einmal nehmen warum
warum trendet helene fischer auf twitter was ist denn da schon wieder los helene fischer
und florian silbereisen alles ist aus oh mein ganz schrecklich hätte ich das jetzt nicht
erfahren über twitter da wirklich der tag im arsch gewesen ich wusste was kompiliert
gerade ein das wollte ich über nacht laufen das war ich nicht genau weiß wie lange das
geht aber doch ich habe schon mal also wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich eine stunde oder so das kannst
nebenbei machen erstmal hier ausblenden max kauft jedem zuschauer ein geschenk so sieht
aus ja ich kauf euch ich schenke euch ein amazon ref link amazon ref links sind ganz
tolle geschenke also mal hauptsächlich für mich aber ich mein ab und zu mal ist es
sicher weihnachten ich kann jedem einen 0,1 cent g2a gutschein schicken dann bin ich
pleite weil da kommt ja noch g2a pay gebühren drauf und g2a shield gebühren und was auch
immer die noch alles für gedürzt habe übrigens eine schöne sache ich habe es ja gestern
auf lautstärke komisch ich habe es ja gestern auf an dem moment das liegt an mein das hört
ihr gar nicht das liegt an meinem headset irgendwie ist das der ansicht dass ich nur
noch links richtig laut bin was das jetzt besser das ist übrigens nicht das headset
ich habe immer noch das rx 300 das funktioniert nach all den jahren immer noch super das beste
headset was ich gekauft habe eines der wenigen headsets die geld wert sind und das ist die
verlängerung die ich habe ich habe so eine verlängerung mit mute knopf dass ich drauf
hauen kann im zweifelsfall ja übrigens also eine sache die ich gestern ja auch auf twitter
gepostet habe ist also wer noch ein tablet sucht der kann sich wirklich so ein ding hier
kaufen ich habe auch ein reflink für euch am starte kanada die teile also die gab es
in dieser cyber monday woche oder so gab sie für ein paar 90 oder so habe ich die geholt
zwei stück nämlich um es an die wand zu hängen ich suche nämlich immer noch neue neue dashboards
die ich an die wand hängen kann wo man heim automatisierungs zeug darauf anzeigen lassen
kann das aktuell ist es so es hängt eins bei mir am bad unten und es hängt eins unten
an der eingangstür aber die sind alt und kacke und jetzt habe ich jetzt zwei davon
gekauft und das schöne ist an den tablets erstens kosten sie nur 100 euro ungefähr
ja man kann auch mal eine aktion abwarten da kosten sie nur 95 aber das schöne ist das
ist ja super subvention warum habt ihr eigentlich alle so so einkaufskörbe im twitch chat neben
euch ah ne das ist der neue button wo ich die nachrichten löschen kann also ja hat
ihr auch gekriegt oder joe joe war es ne ich bringe die name ein bisschen durcheinander
also was ich zu dem tablet noch sagen wollte es ist ja brutal subventioniert durch amazon
ne das ganze ding ich meine bei dem preis muss man sich nicht wundern das hat eine halbwegs
anständige cpu drin ist jetzt nicht der wahnsinn aber für ein bisschen für ein bisschen surfen
und twitch gucken oder so und was man halt um tablet macht reicht es es auf jeden fall
schneller als das shield tablet oder vielleicht haben sie auch das shield tablet mittlerweile
kaputt gepatcht weil ich hatte hier privat für mich schon eine ganze weile so dass das
shield das ist ein video shield tablet am start und das fühlt sich hier deutlich schneller
an ja und was ich jetzt eigentlich darauf ich eigentlich raus will bei der ganzen geschichte
ist man kann das mittlerweile routen weil es gibt leider noch kein custom rom das ist
das einzige was fehlt man kann das man kann das mittlerweile routen man kann das deep
loaten geiles wort oder also das ist das gegenhalt von zunehmen man kann das deep loaten man
kann den lock screen die werbung entfernen man kann amazon zeugs deinstallieren wenn
man das nicht haben will wichtig ist erstmal dass man das ganze routen kann und der hit
ist wenn man nen custom launcher drauf machen wie nova launcher oder sonst was und dann
braucht man ich habe im internet so viele so viele anleitungen dazu gefunden wie man
das machen soll angeblich gibt es dann so nen so nen start button hijack programm was
dann den anderen launcher aufmacht aber es viel einfacher wenn man danach guckt es gibt
nen script das entfernt den ganzen amazon kram unter anderem auch den amazon launcher und
dann ist der amazon launcher weg und ist noch ein launcher drauf und damit gestartet das
heißt man installiert sich einfach google play drauf nova launcher routet das ding deep
loatet das und man sieht nie wieder was von amazon nichts ich hab nicht eine amazon werbung
auf dem ding gesehen bisher also dafür lohnt sich vom preis her eindeutig und man sollte
bloß drauf gucken dass wenn man es wenn man sich das gekauft hat dass man es nicht ins
wlan hängt ja moin patrick ja ein max stream ich hoffe dass ich ab jetzt jeden tag streamen
kann hoffe ich gucken ja mich ärgert das auch immer wenn ich so wenig streamen soll weil
man sieht ja dass es fast bringt ja die letzten die letzte aktive streamphase die ich hatte
wo ich irgendwie drei vier wochen oder so sau oft gestreamt hab da hatte ich ja teilweise
auch bei normalen streams irgendwie über knapp übertragener zuschauer kurz peak ja immer
aber einfach so übelst nice ja natürlich dauert das immer wieder ein bisschen bis
ich das erholen aber so ja so viel so viel eigentlich eigentlich zum tablet also das
ist schon nicht schlecht das lohnt sich für den preis auf jeden fall und wenn ihr wenn
ihr anleitungen zum zum die plauden und so sucht dann guckt einfach bei google gibt es
ganz einfach man darf nicht vergessen twitch ist eine amazon plattform die wollen wahrscheinlich
nicht so sehr nicht so sehr dass ich mich jetzt hier über das routen und flaschen von
amazon tablets auslasse haben wir wahrscheinlich könnte ich mir vorstellen was dagegen könnte
ich mir vorstellen besseres internet für deutschland wäre ein gutes geschenk ja das
stimmt denn oa schreibt ich brauche noch ein geschenk für meine mutter jemand einen besseren
vorschlag als parfüm ich war für meine mutter auch noch geschenke ich brauche eigentlich
nicht für viele leute geschenke aber paar sachen brauche ich noch und ich habe ich
habe im endeffekt auch noch nix ich habe ein paar sachen so ein paar ideen was ich machen
könnte aber ich habe eigentlich keine keine ahnung ja wo ich mal gucken jetzt müssen
wir auf amazon gucken aber ich muss wir müssen mal hier seht ihr das wenn ich rüber switch
auf dem zweiten desktop seht ihr das mal ich muss gerade mal meinen vorschau bildschirm
gucken nicht oder man sieht das gar nicht wenn es rüber switch kann das sein oder bis
mal an dem moment mein stream ist einfach soweit ich habe doch low latency stream es
müsste es müsste es müssten quality options an sein und low latency stream weil gar nicht
warum näher zumindest ich werde mal nebenbei jetzt und gerade schon dabei sind was das
kann in der zwischenzeit laufen ich werde mal nebenbei soll ich euch mal was ekliges
zeigen was richtig was richtig ekliges komm ich zeige euch mal was ekliges es ist aber
nicht gegen die twitch tost das kann ich gleich sagen und es ist nicht windows ich muss ich
muss aber kurz mal den stecker rein stöpseln dazu ohne kiste drüber stellen dass mich
keiner sieht also ja nee also was ich euch zeigen wollte ist ich hab mir eine kamera gekauft
und zwar für ich hab sie auf twitter schon mal kurz geschrieben warte mal hier twitter
muss ich da muss ich euch die sache drumherum erzählen aber das ding ist das gerät ist
für den preis echt nicht übel habt ihr das schon gesehen zu viel bis hängen geblieben
da hat sich der endlost life auf meine raspberry zero gebaut und das relay da oben drauf beziehungsweise
unten drunter hatte die ganze ja ja und ich war kurz davor mir eine mir eine concrafter
kran concrafter oder ich blick dann ich ja ich glaube concrafter pizza zu kaufen aber
es gibt concrafter und es gibt krancrafter oder warum gibt es so viele krancrafter was
ich jetzt hier habe ich eingebaut an meiner klingel vorne hier sieht man es besser das
da hinten ist die alte klingel die der opa eingebaut hat davor ist so eine so eine metall
platte und da ist die neue gegensprecher lade drauf und dahinter habe ich jetzt ich war
hab ich nicht da ich kann sein dass ich euch schon mal gezeigt hab zumindest war das ein
riesen akt ich hab tagelang das war auch so eine sache die mich im december so viel zeit
gekostet hat ich habe tagelang gesucht wo die kabel bei uns im keller wo die lang gehen
es ist wirklich da ich habe keine ahnung wer diese kabel ja doch ich weiß wer die kabel
gelegt hat aber so beschissen ich habe wirklich ein paar tage lang gesucht bis ich es gefunden
habe und zumindest habe ich jetzt geschafft ich habe ein freies ader ein paar gefunden
weil neue kabel legen kannst du bei uns komplett vergessen das kriegst du nicht durch da waren
in weißer voraussicht haben die da keine keine schläuche durchgezogen oder sonst was
man muss aber zu ihrer verteidigung sagen da waren ja vorher auch keine schläuche drin
also das haus stand ja schon das haus wurde nicht neu gebaut das heißt es ist schwierig
jetzt in vorhandenen löchern da jetzt irgendwie schläuche rein zu kriegen naja zumindest
habe ich ein freies ader ein paar noch gefunden von so einem normalen kupfer verlege kabel
also ein bisschen dicker als netzwerkabel so und habe ich mir nach scheiße was machst
du denn jetzt mit einem ader ein paar da ist ja nicht viel zu holen normalerweise also quasi
wenn man hier kabel wie heißt das ja genau ich kann mir diese abkürzung nicht mehr ja
genau dass diese dinger da also so normales so normales kabel das ist wie gesagt kein
netzwerkabel das so und davon habe ich noch ein ader ein paar frei gehabt hier so eins
und da habe ich mir gesagt wie kriege ich denn jetzt da vorne die gegensprechanlage
die übers netzwerk geht wie kriege ich die dann jetzt über ein ader ein paar da dran
das funktioniert doch im leben nicht es gibt zwar irgendwelche speziallösungen dass man
zum beispiel was mit nur eine ader sowas gibt es nicht das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen also
zwei sachen ich brauche einmal strom vorne für die gegensprechanlage und ich brauche daten zeug
für die gegensprechanlage vorne und ich habe nur zwei adern es gibt so ein paar sonder dinger
dass man über zwei kupfer pare essen hat und poe machen kann aber kostet irgendwie noch mal 300
euro und jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich trink 17 gemacht ich habe einfach einen netzteil
in zwölf voll netzteil genommen und an die an die zwei adern geklemmt und draußen habe ich
einen draußen habe ich dass das hier das kommt in wirklichkeit kommt das alles hier hier oben
raus hier ist das dran man sieht es hier nicht richtig das kabel ist kommt hier raus und dann
ist es hier im endeffekt dran und dass das netzteil was quasi in den poe injector reingeht und der
poe injector injecte dann in den access point und der access point übelst übelst um die ecke
ja richtig also das ist schon echt massiv poggers dass das überhaupt funktioniert und der access
point injected dann in die kamera beziehungsweise gegensprechanlage die dann hier noch dran kommt
nehmen das muss man schon sagen das ist schon sehr nice ja wie bin ich jetzt eigentlich darauf
gekommen ja ach ja genau ich wollte euch was ekliges zeigen mittlerweile ist die kamera auch
gestartet beziehungsweise die gegensprecher und zwar ich habe mir eine billig china zipp
gegensprechanlage gekauft und zwar eine hick wischen habe ich gekauft weil es in dem angebot
gab für knapp 75 euro habe ich mir gesagt da kann man eigentlich nichts falsch machen und zwar habe
ich mir müssen wir müssen wir die richtige seite suchen das ist wieder so typisch china kram da
findest du nix so netzwerk kameras video recorder gegensprechanlagen und zwar das ding hier habe
ich mir geholt villan dort stage siehst du schon mal wie fail diese die die seite schon wieder
ist hier die die vandal resistent da bell das ding habe ich mir geholt kann ich irgendwo für 75
euro es gibt es normalerweise findest du auch sonst nirgendwo zu kaufen guck mal hier alter
85 75 gekriegt du kannst im endeffekt nichts falsch machen und ich meine es ist jetzt nicht
das schönste ding ich meine es ist nicht das schönste ding aber es funktioniert so und das
erste was ich festgestellt habe ist nachdem ich gekauft habe ich habe mir gar nicht großartig
eingeguckt das erste was ich festgestellt habe ist die zipp funktion ist absolut trocken typischer
china kram funktioniert überhaupt nicht wenn du heute ich ich drücke mal kurz drauf wartet mal
also eigentlich sollte bei dem bei dem drücken auf den knob vorne den zip call abgesetzt werden aber
stattdessen kommt folgendes also die zipp funktion kann sie von dem ding komplett vergessen da
müssen wir die nächsten tage calling fail erzählte einfach da müssen wir die nächsten tage noch was
basteln weil ich habe mit wireshark schon ein bisschen die der netzwerk traffic mitgeschnitten
von dem ding und ich glaube ich habe verstanden wie das ding two way audio macht also sprich
sprechen und empfangen da basteln wir uns eine mini gegensprechanlage mal selbst weil sieb
funktioniert so und dann habe ich mir okay guck sie einfach mal das web interface an und jetzt
kommt jetzt kommt habe ich mir so gedacht ok machst du mal das web interface auf sagt
nichts zu meiner tollen ip vergabe und das erste was mich begrüßt ist das web interface
funktioniert nicht warum geht das web interface nicht bis ich dann drauf gekommen bin das ist
ein fucking aktiv x-panel aktiv x in 2k 18 leute so und jetzt zeige ich euch mal noch was
ekligeres ich bin deswegen mache ich das auch in der windows vm hier ne windows vm und da habe
ich mir gedacht komm jetzt machen wir mal internet explorer auf und und installieren mal im
internet explorer grandios schweres password installieren wir mal im internet explorer mal
ausplanten also hat sogar nightwish die kamera also die liegt gerade in einem kasten drinne
im kasten mit papier liegt die gerade drin deswegen sieht man da nicht an so viel ich muss
jetzt halt gucken dass man nicht sieht und ja hiermit kann man dann gegensprechstelle machen
und diesen gegensprechstelle eigentlich wollte ich weihnachtsgeschenke kaufen aber wurscht für
alle nups was ist das was aktiv x aktiv x ist quasi so ein bisschen was wie flash nicht wirklich
sagen wir ein bisschen was wie flash allerdings von microsoft entwickelt und nur im internet
explorer jemals verfügbar gewesen was ist für den arsch das ist seit zehn jahren oder so nicht
mehr support aber manche halten es auch im jahr 2018 für sinnvoll so und da habe ich hier unten
bisschen rumgespielt mit mit gegensprechanlage vom audio ne also flächend schlechter ja ungefähr so
und hab dann mal hier wireshark mitgeschnitten also wer das nicht kennt das ist ein programm wo man
wo man netzwerkverkehr mitschneiden kann und hier habe ich dann raus gekriegt ich weiß ich gebe
zuletzt hat überhaupt nichts mit weihnachtsgeschenken zu tun aber dass das kann ich jetzt wo ich jetzt mal
los weil alles dann habe ich dann hier raus gekriegt was dieses ding hier macht zum beispiel zum
beispiel ruft das ruft das hier so eine url auf isapi system two way audio channels ein audio channel channel one audio data und
ja ohne ssl encryption was glaubst du denn glaubst du nicht dass das verschlüsselt ist wer in 2018
den actif x element am start hat der verschlüsselt nix man kann also übrigens aber aktivieren aber
steckenlärm language except language china ja das fällt mir jetzt erst auf except language chinesisch
plain login immerhin immerhin ditches aus ja kein keine keine also du kannst jetzt hier nicht
wobei doch kann es egal zumindest habe ich mir den traffic mal angeguckt und ich weiß nicht ob
euch das auffällt aber der traffic da ist irgendwas da ist irgendwas dran verkehrt und ich zeige euch
mal den ausschnitt und vielleicht kommt eher drauf was damit nicht stimmt moment ich muss ich muss
erst mal das richtige suchen dass das falsches get ich muss das putt suchen hier putt den brauchen
wir übrigens auch ganz geil wenn ihr was mit geschnitten habt den wire shark könnt ihr sagen
hier follow tcp stream und dann kriegt ihr alle pakete zu der verbindung ausgesucht also jetzt
gucken wir uns doch mal den den die die pakete an und das da ist irgendwas ganz merkwürdig
dran und zwar als erstes sehr so sieht man schon was du was dir was die in china für
dinger programmieren also das erste was man sieht ist übrigens wenn ich im chat was über
seh schreibt schreibt er von dauer mit mit entwobblers ich bin gerade so am erzählen und man merkt
dass ich lange nicht mehr gestreamt habe also man sieht hier als erstes macht das ding also
dieses active x steuerelement wenn man auf mikrofon drückt als erstes macht es hier einen
htp putt request an diese uhr das ist ja noch ok na das ist der inhalt hier drinnen ein
bisschen xml auch noch xml es reicht der active x reicht dann nicht aber da muss das scheit
auch noch xml sein also es gibt es gibt es wenn schon dann alles scheiße so und jetzt
jetzt wird's merkwürdig guck mal ich ich das bin ich hier 1221 68 260 und das ist die
kamera 1134 ich mache einen putt an die kamera und ich krieg eine antwort so was fällt euch
auf also das offensichtlichste was hier nicht stimmt also das alleroffensichtlichste also
quasi die hälfte des fensters quasi welche ee war eigentlich in xp 7 kam dann irgendwann
wahrscheinlich 5 7 2000 war was weiß ich keine ahnung ok ich dann werde ich das ganze mal
auflösen was was einem das erste was einem hier an diesem traffic komisch vorkommt ist
den dürfte es gar nicht geben diesen traffic hier den dürfte es überhaupt nicht geben
und warum dürfte es den nicht geben weil htp immer aus aus aus anfrage und antwort
steht und hier ist meine anfrage und hier ist meine antwort genau daniel genau das ist
es genau das ist es also und wenn wir uns jetzt mal das geht nicht dass das das ist
in htp nicht vorgesehen in htp hast du immer du schickst immer eine anfrage und du kriegst
immer eine antwort und wenn du noch was willst schickst du noch eine anfrage und kriegst
wieder eine antwort htp ist in der beziehung dass das starste protokoll was man sich so
vorstellen kann du schickst eine antwort immer immer das heißt nachdem du eine antwort
gekriegt hast und das ist die gleiche tcp verbindung das nächste was ich sehen müsste
ist eine neue anfrage von mir hei worum gehts ich zeig grad was meine china gegensprechanlage
für komische dinger macht ja thera fox das ist chinesische websockets im endeffekt sowas
in der richtung ist das wahrscheinlich zumindest wenn wir uns jetzt mal den traffic angucken
da sehen wir auch hier es ist irgendwie ein bisschen fail das ding das ding das ist eine
anfrage von mir von von diesem actifix steuerelement das ding antwortet mir und danach schickt
das einfach wild irgendwelche audiodaten und ich wollte es mal auf die schnelle nachprogrammieren
habe ich habe ich versucht eine c-sharp konsolenanwendung aufzumachen das basteln wir aber bis basteln
wir aber die nächsten tage basteln wir da eine gegensprechanlage für ich habe versucht
eine c-sharp konsolenanwendung zu basteln und habe versucht mit dem in dotnet beziehungsweise
in dotnet framework eingebauten htp tools diese anfrage zu bauen die hier es geht nicht
was sagt ihr an jeder ecke exception format falsch protokoll violation das lässt dich
diese anfrage lässt dich das nicht bauen das geht nicht weil das nicht absolut nicht
standardkonform ist was die chinesen hier treiben das heißt wir müssen damit wir das
machen können müssen wir uns selbst den tcp socket aufmachen und dann darüber zeugs zur
kamera werfen so so viel dazu also ganz wirre china dreck im endeffekt das macht übrigens
in beide richtungen also das hier ist der putt das sind quasi die mikrofon daten die
ich dann da hinschicken müsste wenn wir sowas bauen und ja und umgedreht macht es mit einem
get auch für die sachen die es aufnimmt naja gut ich spreche auch ganz chinesisch naja
so gehen wir wieder amazon zurück ok wo sind wir wo sind wir eigentlich ursprünglich stehengeblieben
ich wollte weihnachtsgeschenke kaufen aber das ist schon geil oder ich mache ich mache
man dieses ich mache das mal zu ich muss ich muss es mal ausmachen
eigentlich wollte ich noch kompilieren anwerfen aber wird wahrscheinlich zu spät
so aber schon geil oder absolut komplett am standard vorbei china kram komplett vorbei
weiß auch nicht was mit ihnen los ist ok so weihnachtsgeschenke was könnte man
dann für weihnachtsgeschenke also ich habe ein paar ich habe ein paar idee ich brauche auf
jeden fall also ich brauche auf jeden fall ein paar sachen für meine mutter ich brauche
wahrscheinlich theoretisch auch was für meinen vater und ich brauche was sehr unverfängliches
für ein grill für ein sehr nices grill aber das muss irgendwas ja was neutrales sein oder
so also keine herzchen oder sowas und und auch keine und und und auch keine unterwäsche
und vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt schlagbohrer oder sowas vielleicht nicht das beste geschenke
moin elschox also als erstes ich habe ein paar sachen aufgeschrieben die ich kaufen
will oder die die ganz gut werden und zwar als überlegt ich kann meine mutter kann ich
eine ich weiß nicht wie das heißt es gibt für den garten irgendwie so so so teile wo man
quasi in der passenden größe aus dem boden sachen stechen kann also quasi so eine garten
wie heißt sowas stech hilfe oder sowas geschenk für die mod titel gut für ein wie heißt
das denn garten aus stech aus stecher nein ja ja sowas in der richtung plus in groß
wie heißt denn das stech hilfe was ich traue mich da gar nicht danach zu suchen was
findet man denn da akku check keine ahnung bist du sicher dass es rechtzeitig ankommt
nur ja amazon sagt es kommt schon bis freitag sieht das so aus wie eine förderschnecke
ne pflanzhilfe oder es klingt gut also der eichler ist dagegen der heichler weiß bescheid
sowas will ich genau sowas will ich haben eine pflanzhilfe eine floraga zwiebel pflanzer
ein blumen zwiebel pflanzer ein zwiebel sind warum sind das alles noch zwiebel ach nee
mit zwiebel meinen das was man in boden steckt nicht nicht dass man zwiebeln damit
oder es ist wenn man wenn man vampire im garten hat kann man auch gleich noch hier bis zum
blumen zwiebel stecher stimmt ohne prime voraussetzung nach weihnacht ganz schlecht
was das kann man sich auch was anderes vorstellen prime neue angebote gibt es das
gibt es das ding auch gibt es das ding auf vor ohne prime dann wird es nicht gekauft
wenn wir das ding gekauft der flor floraga was haben sonst noch so zu bieten der wolf machen
die die scheren wolf mehr das was anders der pflanzomat das ist das ding können aus
plans verse zombies kommen oder der ex klu pflanzomat pflanz pflanz saumat
wer auch immer sich das ausdenkt warum gibt es ein das ding hier nicht als prime was das hier
wird das nicht als prime ich würde das eigentlich das kommt alles so spät 4.
januar 28. december 3. januar das kommt alles viel zu spät doch das meiste zeug gibt es
prime kann ja prime filtern amazon es will mich amazon aber echt verarschen oder prime
nein wozu gibt es diesen prime filter da eigentlich prime nicht prime achtung achtung
prime nicht prime prime und wo gibt es kein prime da das ist die bait die wollen ich würde es noch
kauf irgendwo ist die bait ok na das firma speichern bestellt ist erst morgen früh ok gibt es da noch irgendwas in der richtung dena knieschoner auch so was
natürlich auch sehr nahe das ist cool wenn sie wenn sie ihre ihre gartenstelle anfälle hat dann kann
sie sich das anziehen also quasi die kammer das in kombi auch das ist nice das kann man kombination
kaufen dann kaufe ich hier so einen so ein spiegel pflanzer und so ein knieschoner dann kann man
quasi mit geschonten knien das ist trash warum ist das trash quatsch die scheiß bewertung
war davon abgesehen ist dass das das zieht sich kauf noch blumen zwiebeln dazu die idee ist gar
nicht so schlecht aber sowas gibt es nicht bei amazon oder sowas gibt es scheiße sowas gibt es
bei amazon warum klar gibt es glaube ich habe noch nie gartenzeug bei amazon gekauft keine ahnung
green brokers limited blumen zwiebeln sechs verschiedene ok nice kann man alles alles kaufen sehr nice auch guck mal das ist da das ist der der das ist die einpflanzhilfe mit am spieß
sagt mit was was sagt mir etwas dass du bei amazon nicht kaufen kannst was man irgendwie im alltag braucht schnitzel ja und ja ich weiß es gibt ein paar anbieter
amazon die schnitzel verkaufen aber das funktioniert nicht richtig das sind auch so komische würde ich
gemeint ganz ehrlich das ich mein wenn man das wirklich essen vor allem warum kostet es 16 euro also das sind 10 mal 100 kramm aber trotzdem also das ist nicht das also das ist also
essen ist noch eines der schwachpunkte bei amazon also frische sachen ja irgendwelche sneakers oder
eingepackte geschichten kannst natürlich bei amazon kaufen habt ihr übrigens schon mal vielleicht habt ihr sowas schon ausprobiert ich habe vergessen
mit das heißt es gibt so eine ich habe letztens werbung gekriegt von so einem laden die angeblich das ist so ein klamottenladen gewesen die angeblich so eine einscannen
app haben da kannst du dich quasi einscannen also die abmaße mit dem handy irgendwie einscannen und dann kriegst du passende hosen und hemden und pullis und gedöns und
einfach du musst einfach nur einmal abscannen mit dem handy ich weiß nicht ob das funktioniert aber die haben gute bewertung auf jeden fall vielleicht hat es ja schon
mal einer ausprobiert von euch ich bin gewillt das zu probieren was gibt es denn heute eigentlich für last minute angebote von amazon müssen es heute wieder besonders
geil aussprechen äußerst die bluetooth zahnbürste es gibt wirklich bluetooth zahnbürste und ich glaube das hier ist eine bluetooth zahnbürste oder ist das die mit bluetooth ja das ist die mit
bluetooth irgendeine variante davon habe ich mir mal geholt und dreimal dürft ihr raten wie oft ich die app jemals die leute sind auf diesen fotos immer so glücklich
seid ihr nicht auch immer so glücklich wenn ihr abends oder morgens zähne putzt und vor allem viel interessanter guckt ihr dabei auch nie hin aber ist schon ganz schön teuer
na ach moment ich habe ich habe eine braun zahnbürste dass das das ding kommt mir nämlich bekannt vor das habe ich doch mal in einem video gezeigt na das habe ich doch mal in einem video
gezeigt die zahnbürste da war auch so ein ding dabei mit dem smiley und das lacht einen an wenn man ordentlich geputzt hat ja aber die bluetooth app ist scheiße das ist wirklich das ist wirklich
müll das ist quasi alles was man sich als gamer so als parodie ausdenken kann ja ist in dieser app drinne zum beispiel putz achievements die haben allen ernst es ist kein witz du kannst in dieser app von von
oral b oder braun ich glaube raum es ist kannst du putz achievements mit deiner zahnbürste anlocken und die nach kannst du dir auf facebook scheren ich habe damals sogar
eng ein video darüber aufgenommen ja die pro gamer zahnbürste genau ich habe mich gerade schon gewundert dass bei mir im wohnzimmer so komisch ausgesehen hat damals ja ja da ist das teil ja
sachen gibt es ja gut use aus absolut useless hit das ist so wie sich die medels vorstellen ja alles geile typen immer
ja ich mache die komische kamera wieder aus jetzt mal ernsthaft kriegst du geld für den klick ohne adblock auf deine eigenen videos ja theoretisch schon aber das ist so wenig das glaube ich nicht
dass ich das in irgendeiner form lohnen würde ich meine du müsstest ja allein schon mal muss dir mal vorstellen du musst quasi für du müsstest mal keine macht muss man
tausend klicks oder so generieren für ein paar euro also das lohnt sich nicht wirklich außerdem muss es ein monetarisierbarer aufruf sein also für einen aufruf wo jemand schon vorher
fünf mal werbe weg geklickt hat dann geht das nicht so was gibt es denn sonst noch so hast du schon feedback zum hardware tool bekommen hast du noch etwas
off stream ja ich habe da noch ich habe da noch ein paar sachen gemacht wir haben sogar mittlerweile einen offiziellen backtracker allerdings privat für das für das tool ja ja das funktioniert wunderbar ich habe noch eingebaut dass die festplatte
partitioniert wird das man das habe ich noch alles eingebaut und dass die jungs rechner neu aktivieren können die schon mal aktiviert haben wobei das habe ich noch nicht eingebaut aber dass die keys wo die aktivierung nicht geklappt hat wieder einfügen können und so was
ja und ich habe ich kann es ja mal zeigen ich zeige es mal kurz ich muss noch mal ich hoffe nur ich habe da keinen echten windows keys jetzt mit drinne
das da ist es glaube ich ich zeige einfach mal für alles ich zeige mal die letzte version davon
warum ich weiß nicht warum das so lahm ist gerade aber es sollte jetzt eigentlich starten
gibt es ein mechanisches funk keyboard was du empfehlen kannst was zudem noch recht klein ist weiß so was beißt sich oft aber sucht schon lange ich habe noch nie
und ich benutze keine funk ich habe keine funken aus keine funktastatur kann ich was habe ich denn hier gemacht das steht noch auf release deswegen geht das nicht ja das kein wunder das kaputt ist auf release muss ich was anderes machen oder ein key leaks
so also zumindest was ich eingebaut habe ist das memeboard ist gerade zugegangen weiß nicht so genau wieso huge key leak huge massive also was ich eingebaut habe ist man kann jetzt keys hinzufügen
habt ihr habt ihr schon die geile animation hier gesehen nice oder eine nice animation also man kann jetzt man kann jetzt quasi keys einfügen neue keys man kann alte alte keys bearbeiten also alte alte lieferungen also das ist quasi eine lieferung oder man kann
ich habe es mal kommentar genannt also alle keys mit dem gleichen kommentar werden hier zusammengefasst immer logs dann sieht man jetzt war das gut da hat sich nichts nichts getan was das ist das ist noch ein bisschen kaputt ja aber das an sich ist wie gesagt achso ja und was auch noch ganz cool ist ich habe eine update eine update war eine update warnung eingebaut also sprich wenn er nicht eine neue version bereitet
reinstelle ploppt dann hier oben was auf mit neuen versionen verfügbar also was ich auch noch eingebaut haben sind paar checks wenn man jetzt hier irgendwie versucht den key zu pushen ohne dass ich einen kommentar eingegeben habt sagt er mir kommentar darf nicht leer sein und pass mal auf pass mal auf pass mal auf nach fünf sekunden fade das wieder auf ist geil oder so wenn ich einen kommentar eingegeben haben falschen key sagt er mir key ist nicht gültig und was war in der dritte fall ich glaube
kommentar und key leer keys können nicht leer sein sehr nice oder ja und wo ich hauptsächlich daran gebastelt habe ist auch hier der client wo man rechner mit aktiviert also wie gesagt das ding kann jetzt ich mache dazu das ding kann jetzt festplatten formatieren beste debug ausgabe ever try 1 try try try try
das wichtigste eine anwendung fancy animation ja das auge anwendet mit quasi und wenn ich mir ich weiß eh nicht so genau ja was die was die da bei google teilweise machen wenn ich mir das user interface anschauen von von vielen google produkten vor allem von den google apps dann dann weiß ich was ich hier
weiß ich nicht was die sich dabei gedacht haben zum beispiel kannst du auf der gucke ob ich davon screenshot finde youtube android tv nein wir wollen keine apk mir aus angucken ich man sieht hier nicht zumindest kann man in doch hier also
wir wollen uns jetzt nicht die rumtour von meg barbie 07 angucken aber das ist eine alte version davon man kann zum beispiel nicht gescheit spulen das funktioniert nicht also wenn man ein video hat was irgendwie
Also wenn man ein Video hat, was irgendwie 2 Stunden geht, dann muss der erstmal 5 Minuten, weil du immer nur 10 Sekunden Schritte vorspulen kannst.
Es ist nicht so, dass das Ding vorspulen würde 10 Sekunden, 20 Sekunden, 1 Minute, 2 Minuten, 3 Minuten.
Das kann immer nur 10 Sekunden vorspulen. Du kannst ein Video nicht neu starten. Ja, das geht nicht.
Also ich weiß nicht, wer diese Apps designen. Du kannst ein Video nicht neu starten.
Also stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid hier und ihr habt das Video geguckt und es ist am Anfang halt was cooles passiert.
Und es kommt jemand vorbei und sagt, Moment, ich zeig dir mal den Anfang vom Video.
Dann musst du manuell zurückspulen, was auch in der 5 Minuten dauern kann.
Du kannst nicht das Video neu starten. Es gibt keinen Knopf. Das musst du dir mal vorstellen.
In der YouTube App gibt es keinen Knopf, das Video neu zu starten. Gibt es nicht.
Gibt es nicht.
Wer baut diese Oberflaschen eigentlich bei Google?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ja, die Twitch App für Android TV ist auch übel schlecht.
Der Future Man. Ist das eine neue Serie oder was ist das?
Schlecht Bewertung.
Instant weg. Instant Trash.
Verstehe ich nicht. Also YouTube App wirklich grausam.
Ja, und deswegen ist es tatsächlich wichtig, denke ich, dass eine Anwendung so gebaut ist, dass sie optisch was hermacht.
Ich finde, wenn man eine gute Anwendung hat und benutzt, dann merkt man gleich, irgendwie, die Typen haben sich was bei gedacht.
Und das stimmt, Pavilion Man. Die meisten Smart-TV-Apps sind scheiße.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum die... Ich hab das Gefühl, die meisten Entwickler haben verlernt heutzutage, wie man Programme für Fernbedienungen macht.
Die haben sich mittlerweile alle so auf Finger getoucht und...
Ja, kurz sagen, auf Maus musst du dich nicht einstellen, aber auf Touch eingestellt, was keiner mehr in der Lage ist, eine ordentliche Oberfläche zu machen.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass es nicht gehen würde für eine Fernbedienung, die nicht mehr als zwei Wattens braucht.
Selbst Cody hat da teilweise so ein paar Probleme mit.
So, Weihnachtsgeschenke. Also, ein paar Sachen haben wir jetzt schon gefunden.
Was gibt es denn heute bei Last-Minute-Angeboten? Gibt es da irgendwas Interessantes drin?
Es gibt übrigens einen neuen WLAN-Standard, habt ihr das gehört?
Also, ist auf dem Weg mit irgendwie bis zu 3 Gigabit oder so?
Und neuen WPA3? Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf, ob es da schon... Oder muss ich mal gucken, ob es da schon...
Was will das Ding hier eigentlich?
WPA3.
Das Ding hat garantiert nicht WPA3.
Router.
WPA3. Router.
Das Ding hat never WPA3. Was soll das sein?
Das glaube ich nicht. Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ein 802.11n und dass der WPA3 kann. Der Typ hat sich verschrieben.
Hast du mitgekriegt, dass Edge jetzt Chromium basiert ist? Hab ich mitgekriegt, aber ich dachte Edge ist...
Das ist aus den Planungen. Ich wusste nicht, dass das schon so ist. Ist das wirklich schon so?
Ja, irgendeine arme Sau muss dir auch Edge für iOS und Android programmieren, ne?
Ja. Das ist wahrscheinlich die Strafarbeit bei Microsoft gewesen.
Nach dem Motto, hast du irgendwas angestellt, kommst du ins Edge Entwicklerteam für iOS.
Hast du noch mehr angestellt, kommst du ins Edge Entwicklerteam für Android.
Ja, das glaube ich auch nicht, dass das jetzt schon Chromium ist.
Das ist dann Chakra GS oder wie das bei Edge hieß, ist dann Geschichte.
So, Tagesangebote wollten wir gerade noch gucken. Was gab es denn hier noch? Socken.
Socken. Socken, Damen, Thermosocken. Socken kann man nie genug haben. Socken gehen immer, oder?
Socken gehen im Zweifelsfall immer.
Jamie Oliver Pfannen. Was hat denn die Pfannenbildschirme mit Jamie Oliver? Also erstens, ja.
Da steht der Name drauf. Das ist so wie Unterwäsche von Heidi Klumba Lidl.
Pavilionmann. Sowelche habe ich auch. Besse. Noppensocken ist das Beste, was...
Wobei, das ist hier wirklich nicht schlecht, ne? Damals, als wir hier umgebaut haben.
Also wie gesagt, ich bin ja hier zwar im ersten Stock. Und damals, als wir hier umgebaut haben und eingezogen...
Also bei einem einzigen, wo umgebaut wurde, da wurde ja auch die Treppe neu gemacht.
Und die Treppe ist so abgeschliffen und poliert, dass wenn du da mit normalen Socken drüberläufst,
zu schnell bist, da kannst du echt sowas von aufs Maul fliegen bei uns.
Wenn ich aufpasste, deswegen sind Noppensocken hier gar nicht so verkehrt.
Übrigens, das kann man noch nicht routen.
Bei Amazon Prime und bei den Tagesangeboten ist so viel Trash immer dabei. Das ist so richtiger...
Richtiger Trash.
Viscars, ja, leider. Brauche ich nicht mehr.
So, ähm, was haben wir hier sonst als Nächstes?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was das ist. Sieht aus wie ein Kassettenrekorder.
Ist aber glaub ich eine Mehrfachsteckdose, ne?
Oh! Alligato!
Oh!
Animus!
Spaghetti?
Die guten Barilla-Spaghetti, aha!
Na gut, die muss ich nicht bei Amazon jetzt kaufen.
Was denn das?
Das sieht aus wie aus irgendeinem Zombie-Survival-Spiel, oder?
Wie aus irgendeinem Zombie-Survival-Spiel. Entweder...
Entweder halt so einen Zombie-Splatter-Effekt.
Oder so eine, so eine, so aus ARK so eine Keule oder so.
Ach, dass sie schinken!
Ach, dass sie schinken! Jetzt habe ich das erkannt.
Norton Security... Oh!
Oh, das tut weh. Geh weg.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Norton Security Deluxe 2019.
Drei Geräte, ein Jahr.
Es ist nicht so, dass man sich damit jetzt mittlerweile nur Windows vollmüllen kann.
Man kann sich damit auch sein Mac, sein Android und sein IOS vollhauen.
Ich werde bloß sagen, dass es eine Niedungsvariante davon gibt.
Aktivierungscode per Post.
Jaja, wir sind schon im Jahr 2018.
2018?
Sehr gut, sagt die Chip.
Und ein mir nicht bekannter AV-Test sagt auch beste.
Und wer sagt... Computerbilder, die dürfen natürlich nicht fehlen dabei.
Und sogar die Stiftung Warentest sagt...
Wozu braucht man das alles? Ich verstehe das nicht.
Ich dachte erst, es ist ein Rucksack. Dabei ist das eine Kamera oder so.
Hat die wenigstens WLAN?
WLAN?
Wifi?
Bluetooth? Nee.
Ah, das ist so eine Kamera, die man im Wald aufstellt und dann lässt man hier schon fotografieren.
Also das braucht doch kein Mensch.
Kein Mensch will ich jetzt mal nicht sagen, aber ich brauche das nicht.
Braucht man heutzutage überhaupt noch solche Activierenprogramme? Eigentlich nicht.
Patrick, hättest du gerne einen?
Lässt dich vielleicht was machen.
Die da? Das ist ja nicht mal Outdoor.
Kameras für ein sicheres Zuhause. Oh, das ist interessant. Ich bin ja eh gerade an...
Was ist das?
Pestreject.
Pestreject? Das Ding heißt nicht ernsthaft? Pestreject? Was ist denn das für ein Name?
It's rejected, die Pest. Die Pest kommt dann an und sagt, ey, du Scheiße, ich kann ja nicht reject it.
Da siehst du schon wieder, dass das irgendein Chinashop ist.
It's ohne Scheiß, Leute. Ihr müsst euch mal in diese Beschreibung schreiben.
Das ist die typische Copy- und Paste-Chinashop-Beschreibung Marketplace Amazon.
Die sehen alle so aus. Die haben alle diese komischen Klammern. Wenn ihr mal guckt, fällt es euch vielleicht auch auf.
Okay, eine Bewertung gibt es. Warum, was ist das?
Passt nicht, ihr Steckdose.
Tja, sieht man ja auch. Passt nicht, ihr Steckdose. Das ist ja schon mal ein richtiger Fail, Alter.
Das ist die Ami-Steckdose. Vermute ich mal. Man erkennt es. Es ist zumindest nicht die...
Es ist kein Euro-Stecker und es ist keine... nichts von hier.
Das ist die Ami-Steckdose.
Vermute ich mal. Man erkennt es. Es ist zumindest nicht die... Es ist kein Euro-Stecker und es ist keine... nichts von hier.
Ach, Kack, ey. Was geht so... Alter, was ist das?
Schlechte Photoshop 2.0.
Das Filz.
Loll.
Ups.
Ich weiß nicht. Irgendwie ist der Photoshop-Typ in China nicht da gewesen, oder was?
Die Einbrecher. Natürlich sehen alle Einbrecher so aus, ja.
Machen Sie sich Sorge.
Den Dieb einschüchtern. Machen Sie sich Sorge.
Fredi.
Was?
Die Familie beschützen.
Sorge um den alten Mann.
Sorge um das Baby.
Vielen Dank für die Verwendung. Ich hab's euch gesagt, Leute. China-Shop, ne?
Und guckt euch die Beschreibung an. Guckt euch die Beschreibung an. Genau das gleiche Muster.
Das ist jetzt ein anderer Shop. Die haben jetzt halt Sterne anstatt Klammern genau die gleiche Beschreibung.
Das ist die typische China-Shop-Beschreibung bei Amazon. Daran erkennt man die.
Und halt mit schlechtem Deutsch dabei.
Wir müssen gleich mal gucken, was es bei AliExpress gibt.
Die Mini-WLAN-Überwachungskamera kabellos.
Auch von Fredi.
L6.
Oh, die ist ja wirklich klein.
L16 und L17.
L6 und L17.
Oh, die ist ja wirklich klein. L16 und L17.
Guckt wieder die Beschreibung.
Value24, das stimmt.
So als ist der Random Rentner irgendwo hier. Kenne ich nicht.
Wenn der Random Rentner hier wohnen würde, dann würde ich mir wirklich Sorgen um den alten Mann machen.
Um meine Wohnung hier.
Also sowas ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Geht die Outdoor?
Outdoor. Außen.
Kann das Ding streamen? Streamen?
Das kann nix!
Das wird ja sowas, was nur mit Proprietärer-Hersteller-App funktioniert.
Ah.
Das ist ja auch nicht so schlecht.
Nein.
Nein, nein.
Alles China-Crap.
Ich könnte wirklich eine Outdoor-Mini-Kamera brauchen.
Also wenn es sowas gebe, was wirklich nur ein paar Zentimeter groß ist, wasserdicht W-Lan und eine Stromversorgung kriege ich da schon hin.
so was hätte ich gerne mit Nachtsicht
das wäre echt praktisch
ok was gibt es denn sonst noch so
Leute was mit euch?
142 jetzt, knapp 150 Leute
einfach beim sinnlosen Amazon stellt
das ist sehr nice
wirklich sehr nice
schön dass ihr alle mit am Start seid
Fackelmann
ach irgendwie ist da nur Crap dabei wieder oder?
nur Müll
lass mal gucken was hab ich mir noch aufgeschrieben
ahja ok
also eine Sache die ich mir auch noch aufgeschrieben hab
sind Reflektorenkleidung
sowas da, ne sowas nicht
sowas da
das sind glaub ich so Dinger die man sich so einfach so an den Arm hauen kann
sowas wollte ich kaufen, das ist praktisch
willst du nach Paris?
meinst du dass ich mein Auto entsorgen kann oder was?
das können die Franzosen in letzter Zeit und in den letzten paar Jahren wirklich gut
das haben sich die Griechen gefühlt auch ein bisschen von den Franzosen abgeguckt wie man Autos anzündet
das ist in den letzten Jahren, guckst du dir so Übertragungen an
irgendwie Frankreich Paris was siehst du brennendes Auto
diese Übertragung aus Griechenland brennendes Auto
Autos anzünden scheint da sehr beliebt zu sein
ja sowas in der Richtung, könntest du mir noch holen
ähm Angebote
da waren wir
äh Sebaro das würde ich das würde ich sogar machen aber ich glaube nicht
dass äh die gerade aktuell in der Lage sind irgendwelche Reflink äh
Subventionsdings irgendwie Angebote da zu machen
das ist ja noch relativ frisch alles
das ist ein Laden aber für den würde ich auf jeden Fall Werbung machen
da weiß ich dass derjenige der dahinter steht die Leute nicht verarscht
und dass der auch gute Sachen baut
äh
ok was haben wir hier noch aufgeschrieben
ähm Reflektorband
Silikonschwamm
was habe ich mir denn dabei gedacht
Schwamm
muss ich gucken dass ich das Richtige eingebe jetzt
Silikonschwamm ja so ja sowas ist das genau
das wollte sie auch haben
ja sowas sowas brauche ich auch noch
so und jetzt habe ich echt keine Ahnung mehr
ähm
ich brauche noch ein Grillgeschenk
und keine Unterhose und keine keine
irgendwelchen
Unterwäsche Geschichten
und auch keine Herzchen sondern irgendwas normales
Chillers
Chiller
soll das jetzt ein Igel sein oder ist das jetzt ein Faultier
Alter Leute
bei dem Chat wenn das die Feministen lesen würden
da wäre der Teufel los ja
mit der unternimmst du was schönes ja aber selbst wenn man das macht
dann ist natürlich schön wenn man irgendwie Kleinkrams irgendwie hat
was man immer mitnehmen kann
weil ich bin mir relativ sicher dass das ja auch irgendwas am Start haben wird
deswegen ist es ein bisschen blöd wenn ich dann gar nichts habe
das ist irgendwas also es geht eigentlich gar nicht mal so sehr drum
was es ist Hauptsache es ist irgendwas
darf ich jetzt nicht zu laut sagen
ich meine so ein Kissen ist vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht irgendwas
bescheuert das da in der Richtung
was zum baden
Staufsauber
Leute
Lassen wir uns
draufklickt
Lassen wir uns noch ein bisschen inspirieren von Amazon Last Minute
Blitzangeboten
Blitzangebote
Alter das hört sich an jetzt krieg ich Donations
Das ist Money
Am Start hört sich an wie der Donations Sound
So ich habe keine Ahnung mehr was ich kaufen soll ich bin wirklich da
immer furchtbar Fantasie los
Dyson ist doch die Oberpro Marke
bei Staubsauber mag sein der Typ ist vor allem über und reich geworden
der Herr Dyson
Dyson heißt ich glaube schon
Tablets im Angebot
ich will mal gucken
Es gibt ein Tablet für 59 Euro
Das ist noch billiger als das Amazon Ding
Was ist denn da drinnen
Das ist schon mal so fett wie
halber Fuß oder so
das Tablet
und es sieht auch ziemlich kacke aus
Das ist 7 Zoll
Das von Amazon kostet aktuell 39 Euro
Das ist das 7er
Das HD7
Das kann man leider noch nicht routen
noch nicht
Gescheit
Deep Loaden und alles
Ja doch ein bisschen aber man kann das nicht routen
Das geht leider noch nicht
Auf Wish.com
Ich gehe hier nicht mehr auf irgendwelche Seiten die ich mir vorher nicht eingeschaut habe
Nachdem mir letztens mich irgendwie einer auf eine Pornseite gebated hat
Kannste vergessen
Gehe ich da drauf
Okay das scheint wirklich eine
Geschenkseite zu sein
Und keine Gebaite Seite
Ein Schal, ja das ist nicht schlecht
Da muss man sich einloggen
Sag mal kennt jemand einen Plugin
wo man diese Kacke, Cookie meine ich
Cookie war noch wo man denen einfach zustimmen kann
Muss man sich da anmelden kann man da nicht einfach so gucken
Kacke Seite
Alle Seiten wo man sich Force an
XXPainix ist donated 5 Euro wie wäre es damit
Danke für die 5 Euro und ich gucke mal nach
Aber ich gucke auf dem zweiten Bildschirm nach
Ich bin immer skeptisch mittlerweile
Ich sehe es schon
Ich muss mir nur den Link angucken dass ich das nicht aufmachen muss
Aber im Link kommt zweimal das Wort Erotik drin vor
Da weiß ich dass das jetzt wahrscheinlich schon irgendein Dildo oder sowas ist
Ich gucke mal
Ich gucke mal auf dem zweiten Bildschirm was es ist
Ah okay
Nee es ist doch nicht es ist
Unterwäsche
Aber wie gesagt das ist viel zu explizit
Nein
Denied
Für ihren persönlichen Vitamin Kick ein Smoothie Maker habe ich schon einen
Und ich wüsste eigentlich auch keine einen braucht
Ich erschenke für jeden anders
Das ist ein Playstation leuchte Ding
Warum
Aber ich sage es gleich schon mal vorwarnung wenn es einer in chat postet oder sonst was
Das hier mit irgendwie verbindung bringt muss ich ihn leider bannen
Ich habe keine schmerzen mit dass es das irgendwo gibt
Ist ja nicht das es schlimm gewesen wäre
Aber ich will nicht dass es auf Twitch ist weil das ist komplett gegen Twitch Toss
Was macht man denn damit das ist ein Playstation Licht
Playstation ja Playstation Licht genau
Dauer leuchten pulsierend zur Musik oder Games und
Ich weiß
Bullshit braucht doch kein Mensch
So soll man das denn brauchen das ist billig aus
Ja das sieht auch billig aus
Es wäre geil wenn es echt
Kann es sein dass der Chat im Stream zu weit unten das
Könnte sein wobei man Forscher sieht es okay aus
Ihr Wolf soll mir das sein soll
Nochmal eine Donation
Ein Euro
Und es ist kein Grill
Kein Grill
Irgendwie ich weiß nicht wie ich darauf komme
Taugt spielt spielt jemand von euch Black Ops Zombies
Taugt die Musik diesmal wieder was
Ich habe ich weiß ich irgendwie irgendwie habe ich gerade an
An diesen Black Ops 1
Zombie Song gedacht
Ich weiß nicht wie ich da beim Anblick von Steckdosen und Herzchen und
Thermos kann drauf kommen
Kennt ihr den noch das war Dings hier
Wie ist die Elena Black Ops
Ja genau
Das da
Das war ultra nice
YouTube
Nerv mich
Die Black Ops 1 Musik für Zombies war übelst nice
Geht ab
Die war übelst nice die Black Ops 1 Zombie Musik
Ich weiß auch nicht wie ich jetzt drauf komme
Headgebanger macht bestimmt komische Geräusche
Ja
Die Black Ops 1 Zombie Musik war sehr nice ist mir nur gerade wieder eingefallen
Ich muss das Bild mal ausmachen
Ja wir sind immer noch bei
Weihnachtsgeschenken
Schnitzel
Das ist doch nicht in den Ernst oder ich habe einmal ich habe einmal vorhin bei Amazon Schnitzel eingegeben
Und was gibt es als erstes inspiriert von ihren Schnibber Trends
Schnitzel
Alter
Und warum kostet es 16 Euro
Ach so das sind sechs Portionen aber trotz
Das sieht ja schon eklig aus
Gibt es dieses Jahr noch ein YouTube Video ich hoffe schon
Ich habe den Fabian schon bearbeitet dass wir wieder was zusammen aufnehmen
Das ist eklig
Es wird ja immer schlimmer
Abgepackte Hamburger
Meinung zur Amazon Kreditkarte ich wusste gar nicht dass sie eine Amazon Kreditkarte
Ist es so eklig dass man es gar nicht anzeigen will oder was
Ich muss jetzt aufhören zu gucken
Ist Amazon gerade kaputt
Kann das sein
Ist Amazon kaputt
Ich glaube Amazon ist kaputt ich habe das noch nie gesehen
Ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben
Noch nie ohne Scheiß noch nie Amazon down gesehen
Bei euch geht es ja das kommt bestimmt ein bisschen darauf an in welchem Teil man lebt
Amazon hat ja nie mal einen Säuber pro Deutschland dastehen
Geil
Tja
Gehen wir mal anderen Browser
Amazon kommen geht
Was
Liegt es am Browser Browser Update machen
Browser Update machen
Chrome mag Amazon
Tja
Kann schon sein in Chromium funktioniert es ohne Probleme
Na gut
Wird man wieder zeit
Um zu updaten
Geht es jetzt
Jetzt geht es wieder
Okay
Postal Zahl liegt
Also wie gesagt mir fällt echt nichts mehr ein
Mir fällt wirklich nichts mehr ein
Da waren wir schon
Ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen von einem
Ich gucke mir in letzter Zeit seitdem ich hier selbst mit Heimautomatisierung am Start bin
Viele Videos in der Richtung an ich habe ein Video gesehen Leute das für selbst gebaut
Für selbst gebaut hat er die geilste Weihnachtsbeleuchtung bzw. die geilste Hausbeleuchtung überhaupt gemacht
Ferngesteuert über Raspberry Pi
Ob ich das finde das war übelst nice
Eventuell können wir besser beraten wenn wir ein paar Background Infos zum Grill hätten
Alter
Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz sicher ich glaube irgendwie um die 30
Hobbies weiß ich auch nicht so richtig
Da fällt mir schon irgendwas ein
Erst mal Browser Update machen
Also das einzige was ich weiß ist dass sie sich zwar für
Technik schon irgendwo interessiert aber eigentlich keine Ahnung
Vielleicht hat sie sich auch nur so fakemäßig für Technik interessiert dass ich
Dass mir das gefällt oder so keine Ahnung
Moment ich muss das erst mal stoppen den
Ich habe zumindest Heimwerke ich habe jetzt zumindest Heimautomatisierung Sachen gezeigt frag mich bitte nicht warum
Das ist eigentlich das bescheuerte was man machen kann
Aber ich meine meine Essens Bestellung war schon ganz schön bescheuert
Vielleicht habt ihr auf ihr habt ihr auf Amazon gesehen
Nicht auf Amazon auf Twitter meine ich warum soll ich es auf Amazon sehen
Ich habe
Ich habe bestellt einen 12er Pack Chicken Wings
Sechser Pack Barbecue Wings und Krautsalat
Bestes Essen
Tja
Das hatten wir hier irgendwie auf jetzt
Was hatten wir denn für eine
Für eine Playlist
Das war glaube ich
Achja ich wollte euch das Video mit der Hausbeleuchtung zeigen
Das war übelst nice und zwar 160 Leute krass
Nice dass ihr alle mit am Start seid
Das Video
Irgendwie so ist das Channel
Holiday LEDs
Ja ich glaube das Video war das das ist die geilste Hausbeleuchtung überhaupt
Wie der Typ gebaut hat
Ich muss nur mal gucken ob das das Video ist
Ja hier sieht man es ein bisschen aber
Der hat ein Video gemacht wo er das vorgestellt hat
Also man sieht hier ein bisschen aber irgendwo hat er ein Video gehabt wo er das gezeigt hat
Das ist übelst nice
Die Software ist auch auf GitHub
Ah hier hier
Guckt euch das mal an hier das ist die geilste
Hausbeleuchtung für selbst gebaut ja
Die man sich vorstellen kann
Und da hat er richtig coole Effekte drinne
Wie zum Beispiel
Sowas oder
Warte da das da
Das ist Feuer
Da hat er auch richtig nice Effekte
Und alles über Home Assistant gestaltet ja ja übelst also wirklich nice
Der Typ hat aber am Anfang
Er hatte in einem Video gezeigt was er hat sich an Netzteilen kaufen muss
Der braucht irgendwie
Der musste sich quasi irgendwie
Ich glaube dreimal 1200 Watt Server Netzteile kaufen oder irgendwie sowas
Dass er den Krams betreiben konnte das ganze Haus ist voll
Der hatte so für Halloween eine Beleuchtung die sah ultra geil aus
Aber ich finde sie jetzt nicht mehr
Gucken wir mal
Irgendwo muss es doch sein
Effekt Rainbow
Irgendwie finde ich es nicht
Wir haben uns in der Zeit dieses Video komplett angucken können
Ah hier jetzt kommt der Effekt den finde ich übelst nice
Guck mal so mit den Augen die auftauchen
Dass das übelst kreative Idee eigentlich
Die er da hatte also ihr könnt euch mal bei dem Channel von ihm vorbei
Für Heimautomatisierung interessiert
Er hat viele interessante Videos zu
Aber den Effekt finde ich halt richtig geil den er sich ausgedacht hat
Mit den Augen
Guckt so
Auge Auge Auge Auge Auge Auge Auge Auge Auge
Das ist so cool gemacht
Das ist der MonkaS Effekt
Aber das ist echt cool
als open hub 2 ich finde schon weil es auf python basis und ich programmiere viel lieber was in python als in java
der eichler nice
ja auf raspberry ist es ist es zu langsam deswegen ich würde mir entweder ein bisschen was schnelleres kaufen als es gibt ja noch schnellere
kleine rechner als in raspberry und raspberry 3 ist zum beispiel auch schon mal gar nicht so schlecht allerdings es gibt
hier von odroid oder so zum beispiel auch noch ganz gute
die sind ein bisschen schneller ansonsten kann man sich irgendwie so einen zeleron
low voltage ding kaufen also ne nicht low voltage
wenig verlustleistung also geht schon
ich habe es auch nicht mehr auf dem raspberry laufen aber war stehen geblieben seite 4 oder so
switch nee nur eine hülle die musik ist zu laut oder
bei der einschnitt ich habe schon auf anschlag bei mir ist es übelst laut
versteht man nicht so genau aber die sound settings unter windows sind eher so eine sache für sich
ja genau hier sind wir stehen geblieben klebeband
also ich würde sagen theoretisch könnte die musik sogar ein bisschen lauter sein aber irgendwie ist die bei mir übelst laut und hier ziemlich leise
dass man das jetzt verstehen naja egal so was gibt es denn sonst noch so
billige led lampen braucht kein mensch mit matratze chat habe ich was übersehen
was ist in letzter zeit bei dir so passiert habe alles von dir bis bettel viel geguckt aber was hast du
danach gemacht vier das ist schon vier jahre her oder drei oder so im prinzip fehlt mir auch
seitdem so ein bisschen das game wo ich so richtig top abgehen eine storm das ist nicht schlecht
blumen gehen immer als das das stimmt schon hast du die flammen lampe gesehen also das ist auch so billig
crap das brauchen wir nicht ja auf overwatch das stimmt ein bisschen ja allerdings hat es hat sich das
nicht gut entwickelt auf erwacht ist merkwürdig auf erwacht ist nicht tot aber aus spieler sicht
irgendwie schon das ist ganz merkwürdig das problem ist bei overwatch das es gibt viele leute
die spielen das halt komplett casual mäßig das ok aber jetzt wahrscheinlich auch jede menge geben
rank spielen nicht so viele was unter anderem auch daran liegt dass es es gibt keine vernünftige
reinfolge irgendwie also du hast oben hast du die erste overwatch liegt also das was die meisten
spieler nie schaffen werden beziehungsweise auch gar nichts für die ist aber es gibt den
overwatch keine anderen sachen irgendwie es gibt so ein so ein halbherzig promoted content aus
geschichte die eigentlich kein mensch guckt aber es gibt keine verschiedenen abstufungen irgendwie
es gibt auch kein e-sport so richtig in overwatch gibt overwatch liegt das war es es gibt keine
third party turner es gibt nichts im endeffekt es ist ganz merkwürdig wie sie es entwickelt hat
ja dass das gibt es gibt eigentlich gibt es kaum overwatch e-sport außer overwatch liegt was
das ganz merkwürdig ist was du bei allen anderen games die erfolgreich in denen in der richtung
sind halt nicht hast guckt euch mal cs an beispielsweise klar in cs hast du auf verschiedene
major events wo auch kein normaler spieler hinkommen wird oder wo die meisten normalen
spieler niemals hinkommen werden geschweige denn niemals oder ansatzweise nicht mal nicht mal in
die nähe kommen werden allerdings hast du noch verschiedene andere competitive zwischenstufen
in in in cs die du spielen kannst aber das gibt es in overwatch nicht was rainbow six ist
dead warum ist normal ist rainbow six dead es ist free to play ja ist jetzt neuerdings
free to play und es hat einen bettel royal modus habt ihr das mitgekriegt es hat einen
bettel royal modus habe ich letztens auf steam gesehen als der mir empfohlen wurde wusste ich
gar nicht reiz mich aber ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht das zu spielen gibt schon genug bettel royal
crap da brauche ich jetzt nicht auch noch irgendwie die play cameras das schlimmste
brauch ich jetzt nicht auch noch cs go bettel royal wie ist gut sagt der arzt
na endlich das ravensburger magische einhorn da habe ich drauf gewartet
spielst du noch ab und an realm royal nein nein nachdem sie das nach ein paar patches so
in sand gesetzt haben dass es keine heldenwaffen mehr gab und ich weiß nicht was noch alles gewesen
ist hat mir das spiel und ja genau und es hat geleckt wie sau aber ok das lasse ich durchgehen
das ist letztendlich auch sehr early gewesen damals alles bei dem spiel aber das hat mir
dann überhaupt kein spaß mehr gemacht und das spiel hat mir richtig gut gefallen und die player
base ist halt auch kaputt na pass mal auf die player base ist komplett im arsch fortnite werbung
geh weg guck mal hier ja guck doch die player base an die geht von rund 100.000 spielern geht
die halt mit den paar patches geht die runter und jetzt sind wir bei 3000 player base 0 und sie
geht immer weiter runter da jetzt schwankt sie ein bisschen aber es ist echt lächerlich das haben
sie richtig verkackt aber der entwickler hat schon wenn man sich mal die oh guck mal es gibt
mal wieder projetti und immer ein mauselefant die haben schon mehrere sachen verkackt wenn man
sich das anschaut silvi unterwäsche ja endlich es gibt einfach nix weihnachten ist zum größten
teil so aus den aus den finger gesauge irgendwie irgendwas was man den leuten so random geschenk
weil ich meine die meisten leute die einzigen für die weihnacht wirklich gute sind sind
halt kinder die sich den kram nicht selbst kaufen können aber alle anderen brauchen den meisten kram
nicht und wenn sie ihn brauchen haben sie ihn schon das heißt du musst irgendwas finden was
er braucht oder sie braucht und was er nicht gekauft hat ganz merkwürdig dufkerzen ja genau
dufkerzen ist auch so das typische 0815 sinnlos geschenk eigentlich das ist so weil sonst nichts
einfällt und weil man halt irgendwas haben will was man verschenken kann weifu kissen wo wo
wo ist patrick wo ist das weifu kissen ich habe es nicht gesehen ja so was so was brauchen wir
sowas brava
ja also viel weniger angeht nicht oder das plujeti gibt es ja mittlerweile in sich war ja es ist
immer noch ein leises usb mikrofon so für den einstieg ist das top
ja das dafür band ein twitch nicht man twitch muss da schon wirklich ordentlich was in die
hose gehen dass man da gebannt wird in der richtung zum beispiel wenn er eine auf pornseiten
gebetet ok was ist was gibt es denn hier schönes man kann es aber auch übertreiben mit schaltern
ansteckdosen schalter schalter schalter schalter schalter das ist zu übertrieben so was brauche
ich so was brauche ich wirklich ich brauche ein bisschen wasser geschützte verlängerungs
ding zwei meter vier meter ja das kostet einfach gleich mal das dreifach ne moment eben hat
es noch 8 euro gekostet warum kostet es jetzt auf einmal hier kostet es 8 euro vier meter
kosten 20 euro und jetzt kostet es wieder 14 euro was das ist wahrscheinlich nur weil
ich da von den sonderangeboten hin navigiere debated ach weil das vierfach stecker dann
die switch da verstehe ja vier meter für stecker das so einschalte man kommt das an
noch mehr socken wozu braucht man dass ich das es ist so viel gibt so viel müll einfach
nur
ne ich glaube irgendwie da finde ich nichts mehr ich muss mir morgen früh echt noch mal
mal gucken warum soll ich dich den modden sehbaro ich demode keinen seien er macht irgendwas
ganz merkwürdig ist keine ahnung wüsste ich jetzt gar nicht was socket klammern das
heißt dass man die beiden paare immer zusammen hat oder was premium nicht einfach nur socken
klammern premium socken klammern bäm china shop ich sag es euch leute china shop diese
diese diese beschreibung sind alles china shops wobei das ist zumindest ordentlich ordentlich
geschrieben ich glaube es doch kein china shop ich nehme das zurück es haben nicht alle
haben nicht nur china shops ohne beschreibung aber das ist eigentlich ganz cool dass das
gefällt mir das ist wirklich ganz cool
jetzt haben wir aber abgekratet von schnitzel packungen oder eben war eben haben wir noch
schnitzel empfohlen bekommen aliexpress kommen wir gucken noch mal was bei aliexpress wir
gucken noch mal was in china gibt wir gucken noch mal was in china zu weihnachten zu kaufen
gibt aber wir gehen da nicht über den ads vielleicht gehen wir doch über die ads
seite hin vielleicht sind dann die sachen billiger was gibt es was gibt es in china
jetzt bis weihnachten da die machen das mit dem flugzeug nach holland und von holland
ja ja easy so was man hier mass ok es wird immer schlimmer was das da fack
was ist das schlecht aus alles sieht das schlecht aus herr krachten das stimmt
nicht der versand aus china ist billiger als der versand aus deutschland kein witz
das ist halt das wie ich overwatch eigentlich spiele deswegen die zwerge sind nice ernsthaft
bei wem brauchst du geschenke ich brauche für meine mother geschenke ich brauche
für mein fahrer geschenke und ich brauche ein grill geschenk ach so ja mit express versand
das stimmt schon aber ich gucke mal wieder was was was seawave seawave automatisierungsdinger
kosten door sensor das ist immer so das ist insofern teuer gerade aliexpress ist immer
so eine sache da musste da musste abwarten wenn du was kaufst aliexpress teilweise für
9 bis 10 dollar gekriegt wwpd nein das ist zumindest noch nicht der fall aber die betonung
liegt auf noch wer weiß ja just for you die ja denken jetzt wirklich welche weihnachtszwerge
kaufen es ist es ist echt schwierig also ich muss mich dann immer voll voll zurückhalten
normalerweise ja also also ich muss das muss das mal bisschen ausholen ja mittlerweile
habe ich mich so an internetsprache und twitch emote sprache und sowas sowas gewöhnt dass
ich dass ich teilweise wirklich einfach sagen null oder irgendwie sowas ja oder monkaS oder
irgendwas in der richtung oder irgendwie anderen anderen internet kacke ja also ganz besonders
schlimm wenn ich den fabian irgendwie am schwätzen bin und auf der arbeit geht es noch irgendwie
ja das sind auch leute die jetzt nicht unbedingt ganzes auch auf twitch rumhängen oder den
ganzen tag irgendwie youtube zeug sich angucken oder sonst was aber zumindest sind die meisten
da halt auch so technisch interessiert uns oder geht das noch irgendwie und normalerweise
hatte ich immer so das gefühl okay wenn wenn da halt so mit außenstehenden namas da mussten
muss musste ich immer muss immer voll umdenken im kopf ja und das habe ich diesmal nicht
gemacht ich habe einfach ganz normal geschwätzt so und das war viel angenehmer ich habe mir
sogar scheiß drauf ob sie jetzt denkt ich habe sie nicht mehr alle ich meine da liegt
es eh nicht so ganz falsch aber ich meine ich habe jetzt nicht gesagt null alter monkaS
oder irgendwie sowas ja aber ich habe mich einfach nicht so zusammen gerissen das ist
viel angenehmer einfach drauf geschissen jolo
Patrick nice ja ein nice mod geschenk also Patrick hätte gerne das hier zu weihnachten
auf was für montaner pleck oder ich habe gehört er kauft sich gerne teure uren am besten
die wollen wir alle so zeug verkaufen jetzt aber teuer erst mal die ure für 18k kaufen
und danach noch neue waschmaschine morgen wieder aber warum sie baro morgen das ist
doch mitten in der woche also bis bald weiter
akenas ich würde sagen das lohnt sich generell das feier hat in zehn lohnt sich eigentlich
für was alles wo wir gerade bei der wo wir gerade dabei sind wo wir gerade dabei sind
ich habe ja am anfang erzählt wie toll ist das overwatch als nächstes ich habe erzählt
wie toll das amazon feier hat in zehn ist also leute wenn ihr euch für das tablet interessiert
weil man es wie gesagt ganz toll routen kann und die plauden und man amazon überhaupt
nicht mehr darauf erkennt reff link sell out am start
das war eh sehr spontan dass ich heute streben so angemacht habe amazon ist wirklich hartnäckig
wir waren jetzt schluss ich habe euch ja trotzdem gefallen wir sind uns wahrscheinlich morgen
schon wieder hoffe ich mal und diesmal auch wirklich macht's gut bis morgen